[Drumming]
Yellow fever has been the scourge of Africa
since the 15th century,
according to oral accounts of early epidemics.
This virus disease is transmitted by mosquitoes.
Man, other primates, and some mammals are
the reservoir.
Historically, yellow fever has remained endemic in the rain forest zone favorable to its maintenance cycle
between the latitudes of fifteen degrees
north and fifteen degrees south.
Yet, as of now, this zone is still expanding
south into arid habitats.
In southern Sudan, the Nuba Mountains are home to a population which,
despite its geographic and social isolation, has been repeatedly visited by the virus since 1934.
The largest-ever epidemic occurred in 1940
with 20,000 cases reported
and a mortality of up to 20 percent.
The disease became endemic and kept creeping south.
At the Naval Medical Research Unit-3 in Cairo, Egypt, scientists from the Rockefeller Foundation
were actively engaged in the study of West
Nile and other arboviruses.
It was thus decided to undertake a reconnaissance in southern Sudan.
The objective was twofold: determine if there had been yellow fever transmission subsequent to 1940,
and then find out if the galago, a primate common in tropical Africa,
plays a role as a reservoir south of the recognized endemic zone.
The opportunity for such investigation was
provided by Dr. Mansour,
professor of microbiology at the School of Medicine in Khartoum and the Sudan Veterinary Services.
They were undertaking the extermination of all warm-blooded animals in an attempt
to eradicate the tsetse fly south of the Bahr
el Arab by eliminating the source of blood meals.
The fly, which transmitts trypanosomiasis,
also known as sleeping sickness,
had been responsible for a high mortality in cattle.
As a result, whole populations of Nilotic,
indigenous people fled southern Sudan.
By interrupting the breeding cycle, it was hoped that people would return to the area and raise cattle,
a source of beef which could be exported
via Khartoum and Port Sudan.
The NAMRU team went along with the veterinarian
teams in charge of eliminating wild animals,
and canvassed the area from El Obeid to Gogrial, making blood collections from humans
and various species of primates. Eleven villages were visited.
As the DC progresses up the Nile, a golden
mosaic of canyons and twisted earth unfolds.
This is the Nubian Desert, a mystical palette of ochres and shadows
transfixed by the abysmal gorge of the river.
The perpetuity of these arid horizons seems to float in a reddish haze of light, heat, and dust.
Much of this is now under the waters of Lake Nasser, because the Aswan Dam was built in the sixties.
The city of Khartoum was built in 1821 by
the Egyptian army.
Its name means "elephant trunk" because here the Blue Nile concludes its tumultuous descent
from the highlandsof Ethiopia and meets in a sweeping curve,  the White Nile flowing from Uganda.
Adjacent to the desert are the irrigated farms of the people who live on the banks of the Nile.
The confluence takes place under the bridge linking Khartoum to the industrial hub of Omdurman.
The color contrast is noteworthy.
These ancient falouccas are still the main
means of transport along and across the river.
Lord Kitchener relieved the British forces led by Gordon and besieged in Khartoum for ten months by the Mahdi.
Chinese Gordon, so nicknamed because of his heroic Crimean campaigns,
remained defiant until the final assault and was killed.
Both statues were removed when Sudan gained its independence.
The tomb of the Mahdi is on the other side
of the river in Omdurman.
It is a holy place of pilgrimage for the Moslem Sudanese.
The blue cupola is topped by the Moslem crescent penetrated by a spear
which is the emblem of the Mahdi himself.
In front of the laboratory, equipment is loaded onto a Jeep.
It is loaned by the U.S. Map Service.
They are busy mapping the continent of Africa from Cape to Cairo
in preparation for the first space flight around the world.
Wherever the British arrived, they developed the railway network, and such was the case for Sudan.
Khartoum became the hub and a transport point for the Red Sea and Port Sudan.
Two other spurs went respectively north to
Darfur and south to Kordofan and El Obeid.
All heavy materiel must be hoisted on a flatbed.
This Electrolux refrigerator is operated with
kerosene and will be indispensable
for storage of field-collected specimens.
The microbiology department involved in tropical disease research
has utilized the railroad system for transporting a laboratory car to various parts of Sudan.
Personal effects and more fragile equipment are loaded in this car, which will be pooled at the end of the railway.
The tarpaulin will provide shelter when specimens are being brought from the bush.
This magnificent steam locomotive will reach El Obeid at the top speed of 35 miles an hour,
and there will be only a few places to fill up the water tank.
The engineers are putting the last nurturing
touches of oil. Recommendations are made.
Everything is checked to ensure a safe voyage.
The two hundred and fifty mile train journey ends at El Obeid in central Sudan.
This is a road and caravan junction on the
migration paths from west Africa.
This is also the end of the railroad and from there the two thousand mile inland trek
to the Nuba Mountains will be on a dirt and sand road, too hard or too soft for driving comfort.
[Music]
Short grass savannah, thorny bushes, acacias
are the main features of the Kordofan province.
As the train stops to take on water, the steam
is converted to hot water for tea.
This truck, taking an audacious turn, is heavily loaded with equipment and personal baggage from the laboratory car.
It also carries the field assistants.
Kasha is the first Nuba village to be reached.
Its round huts gripping the flanks of a volcanic outcrop are typical.
Such hillocks cover approximately three thousand square miles
and range from three hundred to thirty-six hundred feet in height.
Women are returning to the village carrying water collected from far away in large gourds.
Their elongated silhouettes are astonishingly regal and beautiful.
The Nuba people have been victims of Arab
slave traders for centuries and have learned
how to protect themselves in these tiny villages,
tucked among forbidding cliffs and peaks.
Water comes from springs and percolation pockets.
Some tribes have remained isolated from each other with little or no social interaction.
They speak close to a hundred different dialects.
The Nuba are essentially farmers.
They are animists and worship their cattle,
which they believe harbor the ghost
of their ancestor; therefore, it will be rarely sacrificed for food.
These are some of the boys from whom it would
be desirable to obtain a blood sample to determine
whether they have antibodies to yellow fever
which would reflect transmission since 1940.
To befriend the population is a task greatly
facilitated by the presence of Dr. Mansour
who is Sudanese and speaks the language.
These young warriors have sophisticated mohawks
which accentuate the beauty of their profiles.
They often wear on their chest a leather pouch
which contains a few verses of the Koran.
This is for good luck.
Every man carries a spear which is used mostly
for cultivating but also for hunting.
Both men and women undergo painful scarifications
for cosmetic purposes.
It is also a test of courage and stoicism
for the young adults. Skins incisions are
made with sharp knives, thorns or pieces of
glass rubbed with dirt.
hese wounds are left to fester producing the
raised scar known as keloids.
In women, elaborate patterns are added for
each major life event, such as puberty, marriage,
and the birth of children. [Music]
In Talodi, word is passed onto the chief without whom nothing could be accomplished.
A suitable explanation must be provided in order to bleed the population.
Dr. Taylor is an old hand at yellow fever,
having been the director of the yellow fever
laboratory in Rio de Janeiro and ultimately,
at the Rockefeller Institute in New York.
He is an expert at coercing smiles from these
young children. The operation is supervised
with great interest. Four children, twelve
and thirteen years old, tested positive in
the foothills of the Nuba Mountains.
This demonstrated that yellow fever transmission
had occurred after 1940.
This little primate with globulous eyes and
long fingers is a Galago or bush baby. It
is nocturnal and sleeps during the day in
tree hollows.
Local boys will capture them at night by harassing
them in the trees where they are feeding.
The hussar monkey is so named after his red
coat and because he marches in open spaces
with military precision. He is one of the
less common primates of tropical Africa.
The Baggara or cattlemen are nomadic decendents
of 14th century Bedouin invaders.
A baobab tree breaks the monotony of their
journey. It is home to many animals, and people
store water inside its trunk.
The pulp of its fruit is commonly used to
treat diarrhea.
The Baggara migrate from western Africa during
the dry season. They congregate around the
depressions called Wadi where water accumulates
all year round. What role these people play
in transport of yellow fever is unknown.
This large herd of cattle has traveled nearly
one thousand miles and it represents many
breeds. The black Zebu from India with a typical
hump has large round white horns.
The Ankoli-Watusi is a mix of Zebu and a local
African breed. Its large extended horns are
reminiscent of the Texas longhorn.
This is the home of the Dinka who belong to
the River Lake Nilotes, the largest ethnic
group in southern Sudan. Tending goats, sheep,
and cattle is their primary activity.
In this area, water is extracted from fifteen
to twenty feet deep wells and transported
for storage into large troughs. Branches and
leaves are used as a filter.
Mosquito larvae can be found on the surface.
There was no time to investigate these mosquitoes,
which are important vectors of jungle yellow
fever.
For the Baggara, the ox is a common means
of transportation and replaces the horse which
would not survive in this ecology because
of the tsetse fly- transmitted diseases.
Again, everyone carries a spear for protection
from lions but also from cattle raiders and
other possible rogues. The procession meanders
through in the savannah interspersed with
the cautious. [Music]
These guinea fowl are scampering when the
truck appears. This is probably the most common
animal of the area and it provides the meat
that could not be carried on the trip.
This Cercopithecus Aethiops is a common resident
of the jungle. A blood sample will be obtained
during its necropsy.
It is possible to draw about sixty milliliters
from the heart of warm-blooded animals up
to two hours after death.
Specimens collected in the first fifteen days
of this investigation were driven to Wau on
ice for air shipment to Khartoum and proper
storage until the return to Egypt.
A total of one hundred and ten primates were collected.
Seventy to eighty percent of the grivets and ninety percent of the baboons
had antibody to yellow fever.
The number of positive galagos and red hussar
was below six percent regardless of the area,
therefore, these two primates were not a significant
virus reservoir.
The Bar el Arab is very low because of the
lateness of the dry season, but it still requires
a ferry to reach the Mayem Mission. It is
the most southern point of this reconnaisance.
Here the rainfall can reach forty inches as
compared to thirteen in northern Sudan. Lakes,
water holes, and marshes abound.
The curiosity of the Dinka people does not
abate as the Jeep makes its way to the mission.
Our knowledge about the role played by wild
birds in circulating many viruses transmitted
by mosquitoes and ticks has accumulated for
fifty years since the inception of the Rockefeller
program.
Here are ibis, stilts, and egrets feeding
togther. Egrets, of course, are involved in
the Japanese B-West Nile virus complex scenario
which was to unfold in Egypt, and later on
was to be recognized in Asia.
The whale head stork, also known as shoebill
stork, has a melancholic pause for the photographer.
It beauty is debatable.
It possesses an enormous bill with a hook
to dig for lungfish, frogs, and other delicacies.
Two crested cranes are parading their colorful elegance.
They are considered sacred and can only belong to kings.
These giraffes have escaped the veterinary
hunters. This is baboon country.
These flooded areas constitute the Sudd from which the name Sudan comes from.
It is a band one hundred miles long.
It becomes inundated during the rainy season,
as the water flows from Lake Victoria and
into the Nile, becoming a regular river.
It will subsequently reach the Mediterranean,
four thousand miles further north. Thompson
gazelles appear at sunset. Here is the residue
of inundated marshlands.
It's a mecca for all kinds of water birds
who spend a good deal of their life feeding
on the fish and other life essential to their
survival.
When the animals are killed, their skin is
removed, saturated with insecticides, and
put on a frame to attract the tsetse flies.
They will die upon feeding on this poison.
This is another strategy to break the tripanosome
cycle of transmission.
Behind these Dinka are termite mounds. The
material extracted from these mounds becomes
very adhesive when wet and can be used to
build houses.
Two marabout storks comtemplate their domain.
They have a pompous gait which gave them the
nickname of adjutant storks.
Their formidable bill makes them a successful
and rarely-challenged scavenger even for these
vultures which abound in the region.
A new village is being established. The building
of these houses is undertaken by men only.
Some are loosening the dirt from termites'
mounds.
Others are mixing it with sand in a water
pit. The chief is supervising. A very well
dressed Dinka wears three strings of beads,
otherwise, these people, well adapted to the
hot climate of Sudan, wear no clothes.
This social affair is carried at a leisurely
pace.
A dragon lizard is worried by all this effervescence.
He might lose his abode. [Clapping]
The huts have a roof made of straw. It is
supported by a frame to which the clay is
applied in long and consistent strokes. This
is a slow process to ensure that all the nooks
and crannies are filled.
When the appropriate thickness of coat has
been achieved, a process of rubbing and smoothing
takes place.
At the end, the wall will have the blue shine
of a ceramic glaze. But, even in these houses,
people are exposed to mosquito bites during
the rainy season.
The journey ends in Wau from which the specimens
will be dispatched to Khartoum for storage.
Neutralization tests were performed on six
hundred and sixty-six human sera.
They showed that the percentage of yellow
fever positive samples was higher in the south
in the Bar el Arab area. In the age group
of fifteen years and over, the reactors were
eighty percent and thirty percent, respectively.
The occurrence of positive children and young
primates proved that since 1940, yellow fever
had become endemic in southern Sudan.
The seasonal shifting of cattle and people
combined with roaming bands of grivet monkeys
provided all the necessary ingredients for
virus re-introduction and maintenance of the
transmission cycle.
It is now time to return to El Obeid with
a last glimpse of the wildlife of tropical
southern Sudan. In Wau, this DC3 is the workhorse
for transport in more remote areas. It will
bring the cargo of precious specimens to Khartoum.
There is a last look at Khartoum in its magical
robe of sands and at the Blue Nile which separates
the tropical areas of southern Sudan from
the north and upper Egypt.
[End. Original 16mm footage transfered to
digital prior to editing. Copyright: Work
Family Estate and National Library of Medicine,
Historical Collections.]